Mothers are the first female figures boys connect with when they enter this world
This is why setting good examples and demonstrating love and support is crucial right from the very start
But what about those who don't have such a great upbringing from their mothers?
What are the harmful effects on them?
Here are six types of unhealthy mother-son relationships number one
mama's boy a
Close mother-son relationship is important, but how close is too close?
When a mother oversteps her sons boundaries makes all the decisions for him and forces him to be by her side at all times
It leaves him very little room to grow independent as he gets older in
Fact his mother may work harder to make him feel guilty if he doesn't stay in touch with her constantly
the son is often empathetic kind-hearted and giving but his mother often takes advantage of him because of that as
He gets older he may quietly or openly resent her and start to retaliate in order to establish freedom for himself
Number two mother and lover if a mother lost her husband her partner unexpectedly
weather from death divorce or emotional distance
She might try to replace him with her son by having him play the spouse role
The son will likely feel
Uncomfortable fulfilling his mother's needs and may resent the father for leaving them or not being more active in their everyday lives
No one should have to bear the burden of carrying on extra responsibilities. Especially starting at such a young age
This can harm him both emotionally and psychologically
Putting his individuality at risk number three the absent mother
It can create some serious damage when a mother is absent in her son's life, especially when her son is young
According to hope Edelman author of motherless daughters those who grew up without a mother can have trouble forming relationships with others
sons who grew up without mothers often either blame themselves
Believing they did something wrong that caused their mother to leave or they end up resenting them
It's easier to hold on to anger than nothing at all
Number four the boss and subordinate this type of relationship very much takes on the my way or the highway attitude
The mother is often highly controlling and dominant forcing her son to follow her every lead
He is little to no say in expressing his sense of self. He will also have difficulty making decisions as he gets older
this can either influenced him to depend on others too much or
He'll mirror his mother's actions and take control in situations where he feels valued and heard
Number five the hide-and-seek mom this type of mom is often emotionally distant
Her son has a hard time reaching her when he needs it the most
She can be highly unpredictable with her mood swings which makes it hard for her son to get close to her
I'm sure of how she'll react
He learns to also keep a safe distance from her
This type of mother might struggle with giving her son little to no attention love and support
Consequently, this can make it hard for him to form real connections with others
He may learn to build up walls and struggle with social anxiety
Number six the mom and her trophy boy
this type of mother-son relationship
revolves around perfection and expectations in this circumstance
The mother likes to be the star and often puts her son on display like a trophy where she can show him off in front
of others
He's treated more like a possession rather than a son to her
Obsessed with image and performance. She has high expectations for her son pushing him to be better every day
Although he may be your all-star student in school on the inside. He may be secretly suffering from pressure as he grows up
He may be quick to please
Constantly working and incredibly self-critical we want you to remember that you're toxic upbringing does not define nor limit who you can become
What other red flags have you seen in mother-son relationships?
We want you to know that you're not alone and aimed to be a judgment-free
Platform where you can seek support from our other community members
Many of you expressed interest in this topic, so please share your thoughts concerns or any other requests with us below
also
Please be sure to subscribe to our channel for more helpful tips and share this video for a free copy of our magazine on adoption
Awareness use the code psi power with your help. We can reach more people to spread awareness on mental health issues
Thank you for your support really and truly we wouldn't have gotten this far without each and every one of you